[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 3
janvier merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal sur tv
78 faisons ensemble autour de
l'actualité dans les yvelines
et pour commencer cette information
concernant la communauté emmaüs
mediapart révèle qu'un ancien compagnon
a déposé plainte contre un responsable
de l'antenne de bougival et de chatou
ils l'accusent de violences physiques et
d'attouchements sexuels
d'autres potentielles victimes auraient
corroborer ses propos le responsable en
question ni ses agissements et reçoit
pour l'instant le soutien de sa
direction après enquête interne
côté judiciaire l'enquêté est toujours
en cours après les copieux repas de
fêtes et les soirées arrosées célia
cabré coach sportive et gérante de
crossfit farber à plaisir vous donne
trois conseils detox pour démarrer 2020
du bon pied
un mouvement qui est super pour pouvoir
faire tout seul à la maison c'est les
verts peas les beurs peas voici ce que
c'est clément va nous montrer
alors c'est je me pose au sol et je
remonte
voilà je descends je pose les mains au
sol et jeu en entier une version plus
simple quand on a un petit peu moins
l'habitude c'est je descend
tranquillement et un pied après l'autre
je recule je ramène les pieds et je me
redresse cet exercice il est génial pour
pouvoir travailler plein de choses on a
le gainage qui travaillent on a tout les
jambes qui travaillent le fait de
remonter et redescendre
vas-y
on a également en fait tous les muscles
travaillent tous les muscles sont
sollicités
ce qui fait que ça amène énormément ça
brûle énormément de callot et c'est le
mouvement qui vaut le plus de calories
parmi tous les mouvements sportifs et
alors notre conseil c'est de pouvoir le
faire par exemple une série des 10/10
bord pis comme ça et on le fait 5 séries
comme ça et un jour sur deux et c'est un
excellent moyen pour éliminer un petit
peu les surplus des faits
[Musique]
pour une détox plutôt détente
je peux vous proposer une posture de
yoga simplement sa sauce allongé
tranquillement sur le dos posez les bras
bien ouverts sur les côtés placez une
jambe par dessus l'autre et laisser
tomber les jambes sur le côté expiré au
maximum pour pouvoir vous détendre dans
la posture et revenaient tranquillement
[Musique]
au niveau nutrition pour la détox après
les fêtes
la première chose à faire c'est diminuer
les glucides les glucides c'est quoi
c'est le pain et les pâtes c'est les
viennoiseries
c'est tout ce qui à base de céréales
donc sa suite on élimine si on veut par
contre continue à faire des petits apéro
on peut quand même prendre des
cacahuètes mais en revanche on les prend
nature ni sa les négriers
ça c'est la première chose et si on a
encore une petite nostalgie du chocolat
on prend un petit peu de chocolat
m c'est uniquement du noir 85 % minimum
pour occuper les enfants pendant les
vacances la salle de la torah voisins le
bretonneux accueilli pendant deux jours
l'accompagné saint-quentinoise
garde-fous au programme un spectacle
destiné aux 3 10 ans intitulé des
comptes qui font un peu peur mais pas
trop l'histoire de baba yaga la sorcière
qui adore manger les enfants
il s'agit d'une création soutenue par le
conseil départemental des yvelines
un spectacle qui est habituellement
présentés dans les écoles on met en
place un dispositif plus large à savoir
des ateliers d'écriture avec les enfants
pour qu'ils créent leur propre compte
ensuite une plasticienne qui travaillent
avec nous qui s'appelle floriane fagots
qui intervient pour qu'ils illustrent
leur compte et ensuite si un éditeur les
éditions mazette à plaisir qui rassemble
toute cette matière et qui en font un
livre par exemple on en a ramené
quelques uns et voilà donc on a fait ce
projet avec trois écoles du département
l'année dernière et voilà on du taux
trop recherche de nouveaux partenariats
et pour les amateurs de contes la fête
du conte revient à saint quentin en
yvelines et ce dès le 15 janvier de
nombreux rendez vous prévus dont une
nuit de la lecture le 18 janvier à la
médiathèque d'elancourt programme
complet sur kiosque point ski point fr
culture toujours avec l'ouverture aux
perray-en-yvelines du lieu un espace où
les artistes vont côtoyer la population
quotidien une maison ouverte sur la rue
pour des échanges entre générations
dix idées par gwénaëlle saintilan
bienvenue au 33 rue de chartres opéré en
yvelines c'est au coeur de cette
parcelle boisée composé d'une demeure
rurale et de son grand parc que
s'élabore un ambitieux projet social et
artistique dont le rayonnement s'étendra
sur le territoire alentours
le 33 comme on a l'habitude désormais de
la plaine c'est une propriété une
immense propriété de 9000 m² idéalement
situé à proximité du centre de loisirs
qu'on appelle la lsh et surtout de la
résidence pour personnes âgées la rpc
l'association saint jacques qui a
sollicité la commune du perray en juin
2018 pour reprendre une gestion directe
du terrain avec pour objectif de créer
un lieu de vie sociale et
intergénérationnelle afin de faire
revivre ce site est en accord avec ses
exigences
la municipalité a lancé un appel à
projet en avril 2019
s'inscrivant dans une démarche de
participation citoyenne organisée sous
la houlette du collectif les gens du
lieu
les initiatives sélectionnées mais
l'ambition sociale culturelle
environnementale et de loisirs parmi les
cinq associations retenues donc on a eu
le lieu donc si on proposait eu un
projet permanent c'est à dire de
s'installer donc dans le dans le
bâtiment du 33 de faire des résidents
artistes de proposer également des des
rendez vous sur le site cité recycle qui
a pour ambition de proposer 2 de
l'accompagnement collectivité donc
notamment opéraient sur la question la
thématique de la mobilité troisième
association on a eu les pipelettes qui
happe réalisé pas mal d'action
intergénérationnel notamment autour de
l'alimentation du bien manger
achetez grec qui a pour but de valoriser
et promouvoir le l'histoire du père est
le patrimoine même du territoire un peu
plus élargie et enfin la dernière c'est
présence qui a
pour principal objectif de faire des des
actions à destination des seniors
aujourd'hui ce projet collectif et
collaboratif se pose-t-il et dessine une
offre innovante dont pourront bientôt
profiter les habitants
il a été convenu que la partie habitable
de la bâtisse seraient principalement
occupée par le lieu avec une partie
commune également des chambres à l'étagé
pour résidence des artistes pour la ce
qui concerne la grange
il est envisagé d'y faire une petite
salle de spectacles à l'extérieur un
poulailler et un potager participatif
avec également une possibilité d'y
installer une ruche
de l'autre côté du bâtiment il est prévu
une activité réparation vélo il est
envisagé également un café associatif
la particularité de ce projet c'est que
sa dimension sa dimension culturelle au
service du social ce sont des
associations qui vont mettre en place en
plus des activités qui vont vraiment
participer au lien social
l'idée c'est vraiment d'en faire un lieu
vivant ouvert et convivial et qu'on soit
au service vraiment de tous les citoyens
le sud yvelines est assez dépourvus des
espaces de ce type là donc c'est
vraiment c'est un projet qui a un
caractère innovant fort c'est la raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle on le projet il
est soutenu
aujourd'hui on est on est en discussions
avec le département des yvelines qui
souhaitent soutenir le projet notamment
sur la dimension sociale et culturelle
la région ile-de-france sur l'aspect
culturel et le parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse qui qui nous qui
nous soutient dans la mise en place de
ce projet dans sa conception
on attend avec impatience les premiers
rendez-vous publics du 33 fin 2020 deux
rendez vous sportif à suivre pour
clôturer cette édition tout d'abord en
tir à l'arc la compagnie d'arc
d'elancourt organise samedi et dimanche
son parcours annuel en salle 2 x 18 m
concours sélectif pour le championnat de
france phase finale le dimanche à partir
de 16h30 avec des matchs individuels au
complexe sportif europe
et puis en football versailles club de
nationale iii reçoit dans le cadre de la
coupe de france
grosbill qui évolue en nationale 2 ce
sera samedi à 13h au stade mont boron
derniers rescapés il dit non à cette
année les versailles et pourrait défier
des ténors de ligue 1 ou de ligue
2 en cas de qualification et c'est la
fin de cette édition prochain rendez
vous avec votre actualité locale lundi 6
janvier vous retrouverez grégory canal
et en attendant vos programmes se
poursuivre sur notre antenne
[Musique]